that 100 just wouldn't be the same
without actress Eliza Taylor who is best
known for portraying Clark Griffin
believe it or not but Eliza actually has
a lot in common with her on-screen
character keep watching to find out how
Eliza snagged the leading role without
ever auditioning for it I woke up
running in a cell it's been five years
since Eliza Taylor was cast as Clark
Griffin in the 100 the actress snagged
the role when she was 24 years old and
she's held on to it ever since
funny enough Eliza was made to play a 17
year old character in season one it's
super common for young adults to be cast
into adolescents roles so being seven
years younger than her actual character
was never an issue but it looks like the
tables have turned and drastically we
might add because Clark is now much
older than Eliza will ever be the season
5 finale showcase our heroes being
placed into a deep cryo sleep only to
awakened 125 years later so in a way
Clark is currently 149 years old
thankfully the sky crew knows a thing or
two about technology Eliza and her
character are born in October so they'll
both be celebrating a milestone this
year whereas Eliza will be turning 30
years old Clark will be celebrating her
one hundred and fiftieth Clark was born
and raised on the ark her mother Abbie
was the chief of Medicine and Clark had
every intention of following in her
footsteps so she spent a lot of her free
time tending the people's wounds and
medical conditions
a tragic series of events led Clark to
be arrested for treason and sent to
solitary confinement and it was later
revealed that she would be sent to earth
as punishment for her crimes luckily she
was well adapt in the medical department
causing her to become the lead medic of
her crew Clark is a talented doctor and
coincidentally Eliza is fascinated with
the medical world in fact the actresses
two favorite TV shows our house and
Grey's Anatomy so playing the part of an
experienced doctor came naturally to her
binge watching her favorite seasons
helped her perfect the medical lingo
that would soon be thrown her way
however some things were harder for her
to perfect it's old news that Clark's
character is super serious but can you
really blame her after all there's not
much to smile about in the
post-apocalyptic series Clark's a
natural born leader so she's taken it
upon herself to help the sky people
integrate with the grounder
and let's just say that achieving this
is a lot more complicated than it sounds
although Eliza and her character share
many similarities the actors found it
hard to conform to her characters ever
so serious demeanor this is probably due
to how goofy she is in real life
Eliza loves to laugh and joke around so
much so that she used to post regularly
on vines making people laugh has always
been one of her strong suits and she
inherited this trait from her stepfather
who used to be a stand-up comedian
although Clark's lips hardly ever curl
up to reveal her teeth Eliza is
constantly laughing when the cameras
aren't on her that 100 is one of the
most futuristic shows on the CW the TV
series was inspired by a series of
novels by the same name author cast
Morgan had a clear image of what her
characters looks like and producers were
determined to make her vision come to
life curiously though the TV series
aired before the books were ever
published in the books Clarke Griffin is
described as a beautiful young woman
with long and wavy strawberry blonde
hair she's also said to have a fair
complexion and gorgeous green eyes Eliza
is clearly the perfect girl for the job
which is why casting her as Clarke who
was a no-brainer Eliza is known for her
long and wavy blond locks however she's
not exactly as the author described for
one Eliza's hair isn't strawberry blonde
on top of that her eyes are blue and not
green regardless of these differences
Eliza's overall look was exactly what
the producers had in mind
Eliza knew from a young age that she
wanted to be a star and luckily for her
she's super gifted before becoming the
big-time actress she is today she dreamt
of one day becoming a marine biologist
Eliza has a soft spot for nature and
grew up near the ocean causing her to
become interested in this profession
however by the time she was 14 years old
she was already landing her first acting
gig Eliza played the role of janae
Timmins in the hit TV series neighbours
for a total of five years throughout
this time she developed a love for
singing and a knack for playing the
guitar we've seen Clarke sing through
some pretty horrible scenarios on the
100 so it's safe to say that music helps
both Clarke and Eliza cope with their
emotions Eliza is a natural when it
comes to singing and playing the guitar
so much so that you
never expect her to have an Australian
accent many fans were shocked to find
out that Eliza was born and raised in
Melbourne Australia learning to cast
aside her accent and replace it with an
American one wasn't an easy thing to do
but she's an actress and a good one at
that so she didn't struggle for too long
if this isn't yet another clue that
these two characters are perfect for
each other
we don't know what is when the casting
call for the 101st came out thousands of
actors were quick to audition for the
leading roles however Eliza was not one
of them in fact she wasn't planning on
auditioning at all we can't imagine what
the TV series would be like without her
nor do we want to the show's producers
have the perfect person in mind when
casting Clark's role
luckily producers stumbled upon Eliza's
audition tape and immediately fell in
love with the idea of casting her as the
lead Eliza had originally sent this tape
in several months earlier however she
was auditioning for a role in a movie
and not for the 100 Eliza was called in
the very next day and asked to read some
lines and shortly after she was given
the part before you go let's take a
little vote which ship is your favorites
Vil arc or LexA let us know in the
comments below if you love the 100 as
much as we do don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up and make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
see you soon
[Music]